Gojo is so insanely powerful, that even Gege
Akutami, the author of Jujutsu Kaisen himself,
had no other chose but to temporarily
completely remove him from the story
during the Shibuya incident, for
there to be any stakes or conflict
left in the story that Gojo wouldn’t just
solve immediately by himself. However,
there’s one thing he has that really held him back
in the latest episode of Jujutsu Kaisen: Trying
not to be a mass murderer. Or if you want to
phrase it a bit more nicely: his conscience.
He DOES accept that he can’t save every
single person while a monstrous curse
is wreaking havoc. However, he’ll still
always stop short of killing any innocent
bystanders himself. His enemies know this and
that’s why they created the perfect plan to
seal Gojo away in the Prism Realm during
the Shibuya Incident. Happy Halloween.
Having Gojo sealed in the Prism Realm changed
the entire world of Jujutsu Kaisen. As many
characters have hinted, Satoru Gojo’s
power as a Jujutsu Sorcerer is pretty
much the only thing preventing curses from
overrunning Japan. This era’s sorcerers are
supposedly far weaker than those of the
past and without Gojo’s amazing Limitless
and Six-Eyes powers keeping the curses at
bay, the entire world is at risk - which is
exactly why it’s so bad that the plan to
seal Gojo worked. But what if it didn’t?
As you’ll remember, Gojo could have destroyed
all of his attackers in no time at all,
but his attack also would have caught the
hundreds, if not thousands of innocent
civilians trapped in shibuya with him as well.
But what if instead, Satoru Gojo said screw it
and got to display his full power? If just this
once, Gojo decided to pass on his Batman “No-Kill
Rule”, how would he fare against the combined
efforts of Jogo, Dagon, Hanami, Choso, Mahito,
AND his old best friend Geto, who actually
isn’t really Geto, but you get what I mean??
There are a few reasons Gojo might decide to
not hold back and go all out here: First off,
maybe his Geto senses go off and he realizes that
if he doesn’t put an end to his old pal right then
and there, there’ll be a lot of casualties.
Maybe all the train tracks remind him of the
trolley problem and he does the math and realizes
he’ll save way more people if he sacrifices all
of the train station people. Maybe he just wants
to get into the Halloween Spirit by committing
mass murder - the reason doesn’t matter: what
matters is how much he’s gonna crush these curses.
So let’s start with the first combatants:
The disaster curses. This is the second
time Gojo’s had to deal with Jogo
and the third time he’s dealt with
Hanami. He has no more patience at
all for these special grade curses.
In the actual story, he toys
with them as he always does,
but not this time. He’s going to absolutely
destroy these guys. Due to their teamwork,
Hanami is able to cancel out Gojo’s cursed
technique, making Jogo the first curse in
a while who’s actually able to touch the
world’s strongest sorcerer. Big mistake.
Jogo’s power is fire and lava, which burns
bright red. You know what else is red? Gojo’s
Cursed Technique Reversal: Red. This
insanely strong Jujutsu power passed
down through the Gojo has the ability
to repel things using a huge shockwave.
Jogo has grasped onto Gojo’s arm (Note to the
author Gege Akutami - thank you for making
these characters’ names so similar).
Jogo’s grip slightly burns his sleeve,
but his single eye barely has time
to process what’s happening before
he sees the red dot shining
on the end of Gojo’s finger.
Jogo’s body goes flying at insane speeds,
unfortunately causing innocent bystanders
to burst into flames on the way. But hey,
so far, Gojo didn’t technically kill anybody
himself - we’re still going to count those deaths
as being caused by Jogo’s flying, fiery body.
The volcano curse smacks right into the
barrier outside Shibuya Station at top speed,
instantly destroying him in a
fiery explosion. But someday,
if enough people fear a volcanic eruption, he’ll
be born again. See you again someday, Jogo.
Up next is Hanami, who would have been very
disturbed by his friend’s death if he could
see it - but since he’s got twigs for eyes,
it probably won’t bother him much. Speaking
of those twigs, by the time he registers that
Jogo is gone, Gojo has grabbed his eye branches
and ripped them straight out of his head. You see,
the mangaka Gege Akutami already wrote Hanami the
perfect death - so he’ll get destroyed immediately
after this by being crushed by Gojo’s infinite
technique. Hanami loves nature, so it’s fitting
that he’d be destroyed by a freak of nature.
Currently Dagon, the ocean disaster curse
is shyly hiding behind a post in the Subway
Station. Not for long. Dagon holds power over
water. The peaceful, blue sea: and it just so
happens that Gojo also has something blue -
his Cursed Technique: Lapse Blue. Dagon isn’t
going to be hiding for long because he’ll
be pulled toward Gojo with immense force,
breaking straight through the pillar. He might get
a few innocent bystanders soaked along the way,
but by the time he gets to Gojo, it’s not long
before this poor curse is turned into sushi.
In the actual story, we eventually
get to see the full range of Dagon’s
powers. There’s a reason he’s a Special
Grade Curse along with his teammates,
but all you anime viewers will just
have to keep watching to find out
what he can do because in our What
If scenario…this guy is super dead.
The Disaster Curses have one more ally available
to bide time for the rest of the reinforcements to
arrive: Choso, the Cursed Womb: Death Painting.
This powerful combination of a human and cursed
spirit wants to avenge his brothers, the other
Death Paintings. Using his power of blood
manipulation, he fires a shot of blood at Gojo.
However, as we know, Gojo is untouchable. Using
his infinity powers, the blood appears to stop
just short of striking him. However, in reality
the blood is approaching him, just so slowly that
it will never actually reach him because it’s
traveling through the technically infinite amount
of space between any two objects. Math is hard.
Being not at all hit by Choso’s attack
means that Gojo can easily approach the
Death Painting and eliminate him with
deadly force. Choso sadly won’t get
to avenge his brother, but on the bright
side he does get to see them real soon.
It’s at this point that a subway car
rolls into the station. Out bursts Mahito,
laughing maniacally as he reveals his train
full of transfigured humans. “Surely Gojo
didn’t count on this!” he thinks, before
looking around. His eyes go wide as he
sees Gojo’s beautiful blue eyes staring
back at him. He is strangely not occupied
at all by fighting the other disaster curses.
Instead, all of Mahito’s friends are super dead.
Uh oh, how will Gojo deal with all
of these transfigured humans? Well,
similar to the way he does in the regular
series. By activating his domain expansion:
unlimited void. This extension of Gojo’s
limitless ability brings infinity right
into the minds of everyone exposed to it. It
unleashes an infinite amount of raw information
right into the brains of its victims,
completely immobilizing them. They feel
and see and hear everything all at the same
time and are overwhelmed, left to slowly die.
Gojo’s special trick during the
Shibuya Incident was to spare the
civilians this fate by only activating
his domain expansion for .2 seconds,
leaving them unconscious, but not
killing them. However, this time,
his Geto senses are tingling as his old friend
and enemy shows up with the Prison Realm.
In an instant, he knows two things. One:
This is not Geto - I totally killed him. Two:
If I let whoever this impostor
is do whatever they’re planning,
things are going to end up really
bad. You can’t make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs, and in this case
Gojo’s eggs are innocent civilians.
However, along with all of the regular
humans - this also takes out Mahito’s
legion of transfigured humans.
At this point Gojo would be BIG
MAD. Not only has his bestie’s corpse
been taken over by some evil force,
but this team of baddies has gotten him
to break his one rule and kill a bunch
of innocent people. Not only does he kill them
by using his domain, but he essentially forces
them to suffer for what feels like eternity.
He’s not about to let them get away with that.
Mahito can transfigure someone into a monstrous
new form just by touching them. He does so by
changing the shape of their soul, and the
body follows this new twisted shape. However,
as established, it’s pretty much impossible
to touch Gojo. His domain wouldn’t have enough
power to overcome Gojo’s Unlimited Void.
Failing to touch and transform Satoru Gojo,
Mahito would try to run away, but he’d
be unable to make any progress - the
space in front of him would infinitely
extend making it impossible for him to
get away from Gojo before he was hit
by the full effect of Unlimited Void.
Pseudo Geto is another story, though.
This sorcerer has been around the
block and knows more than anyone about
Gojo’s abilities. Using a simple domain,
he nullifies the effects of Unlimited Void and
brings the two back to a more even playing ground.
Pseudo Geto would use his signature
ability to fight against Gojo,
which is summoning the cursed spirits that he’s
captured with his cursed technique. However,
just like everyone else - the spirits
would have a very hard time even
hitting Gojo. And at this point we’re
dealing with an extremely angry Gojo.
He has one technique left that he’s been
saving up and Geto is the perfect sorcerer
to use it on. Combining his red and blue
powers, he uses his Hollow Purple technique,
the same power he developed in order to
defeat Toji Fushiguro. This immense blast
of energy would absolutely destroy
Pseudo-Geto before he even gets to
tauntingly reveal his evil brain or
his hidden identity. Unfortunately,
Hollow Purple would also absolutely destroy
Shibuya Station and most of the people in it.
Ultimately, it’s worth it based on how
many additional citizens of Japan this
move would actually save. And, while also
remaining somewhat vague…there are probably
still going to be some innocent people who
die in Shibuya whether Gojo kills them or
not. The only difference is whether he gets
sealed and even more people die eventually.
After this sweeping move, the show would
pretty much be over. With the disaster
curses and Pseudo Geto out of the way, the
biggest threats to humanity are gone and
Jujutsu High can carry on business
as usual, saving Japan from curses
that are not special grade. You know,
just regular run-of-the-mill curses.
The remainder of the show could focus on
Yuji going on a quest for the remainder
of Sukuna’s fingers and devouring them all like a
delicious gourmet meal until he’s finally executed
by the worst school administration of all time.
Meanwhile, Gojo would suffer from crippling PTSD
after having killed a bunch of innocent people
by his own hand (or his own cursed technique,
I should say). Therapy is a much smaller price to
pay than Japan being overrun by curses, though,
so hopefully he can learn to forgive himself and
return to the same old Gojo we know and love.
Speaking of that Gojo we know and
love - obviously he’s one of the
coolest characters in all of anime, but if
you want to learn exactly what makes him
such an amazingly written character - you can
check out this character analysis video next!